In this final
lecture, we will first
review the various properties
of a nice Markov chain, which
ensures steady state behavior,
and go over some of the notions
in more detail
with some examples.
Providing some insights on
how good an approximation
we have when we use
steady state probabilities
to characterize the behavior
of a Markov chain, which
has run for a long time, but
not an infinite amount of time.
We will then consider
a classical application
of Markov chains, which has to
do with the design of a phone
system.
This is a famous problem, which
was posed, analyzed, and solved
by a Danish engineer
by the name Erlang.
It was more than 100
years ago when phones just
started to exist,
but we will see
that this methodology
remains relevant to design
similar systems
in today's world.
We will then make
use of all what
we have learned so far
in order to calculate
some interesting short
term behaviors of Markov
chains having more than
one recurrent classes.
We will introduce the
notion of absorbing states,
and we will show
how to calculate
the probability of ending
up in such a state,
as well as related quantities
such as the expected time it
takes to do so.
As a classical
example, we will look
at the gambler
continuously playing
a simple game of
chance, say a lottery,
until he either accumulates
a given amount of money
or loses all his money.
Both of these states
are absorbing.
What are their
corresponding probabilities?
After this lecture, you will be
able to answer such questions.